what part do you not like about the
Hillary Clinton about the Joe Biden Wing
what part do you not like so a number of
things first of all do you put Obama on
that camp as well Obama yes I would say
he's like 75 in that camp I mean I could
list some things that he did that I like
but mostly he's in that camp uh I mean
look their Economic Policy policy is
what I would call neoliberal corporatism
which is again a continuation of the
status quo
um foreign policy wise he's hawkish
which again Falls right in line with
Hillary Clinton she brought us Libya she
helped get us the Iraq War Joe Biden of
course helped get us the Iraq War as
well so when I look at him I just see no
change
I see a continuation of the status quo
to you by the way what was most
frustrating to me I like a good fight
right I mean I don't know about you but
I like a good fight like I like seeing
yesterday Luca 60 points 21 rebounds
tennis's first player ever to do it I
don't know if you follow basketball
insane statistic to do something like
that and the guys interview said did you
know you scored 60 points did I I scored
60. I'm tired I mean just something that
you've never seen before I like a good
fight that was overtime I like a you
know uh Joe Bro against you know Tom
Brady or even the World Cup sick a good
fight yeah that was it was so annoying
when the announcement came about well
you know Elizabeth Warren Pete bootage
uh uh everybody else uh Bernie Sanders
is dropping out and they're all
supporting Joe Biden I wanted to see you
have no clue how bad I wanted to see
Trump against
oh that would have been insane I
actually think they have some things
that they agree on which would have been
interesting uh because I don't think
they both like the swamp I think both of
them are against the swamp and it would
also this is the second time they did it
Hillary did that and now Biden did it
which is quite frustrating to see that
happening when you see that two times
and that's your guy how do you feel
about it how do I feel about Bernie
getting stabbed yeah yeah no I mean look
it just it tells you that there are very
powerful forces behind the scenes at the
top of the democratic party that would
pull out all the stops in order to
prevent somebody who would break the
mold from taking power Bernie I think is
more in the mold of an FDR an FDR very
famously took on powerful interests and
what happened is in the 1990s Bill
Clinton came in and he was this new deal
Democrat is what they call or excuse me
not New Deal Democrat new democrat which
just means uh they had the DLC
Democratic Leadership Council they
decided instead of us taking Union money
teacher money we're also going to start
taking the same corporate money that the
Republicans are taking and so they
decided hey look I'm not on the left I'm
not on the right I'm kind of in the
middle and I'm above The Fray and I'm an
enlightened Centrist and what they did
is made us the Democratic party was no
longer a party of working people and
Bernie Sanders was trying to bring it
back to a party of the working people
and they would not let that happen
because they have all the money Bernie
Sanders you know he uh famously his
campaign was built on small dollar
donations and that can get you a long
way but when there's more money on the
other side and they're way more
organized and to your point that is the
organization that you just discussed
when you had you know what was it mayor
Pete better O'Rourke he had all these
people drop out on the exact same day
right before a big election and endorse
Joe Biden if it seems like Joe was doing
great it's not like Joe was he wasn't he
got destroyed in Iowa he got destroyed
in New Hampshire and look if they didn't
do that Bernie Sanders would have won
because so that was the biggest fear the
biggest fear was what if Bernie takes
over and some of these ideas some of
these guys get some momentum correct
yeah and also I think Bernie if Bernie
was President I think he would have put
Obama's record to shame and so Obama
also has a vested interest in in what
way and what we Obama has a vested
interest in not allowing Bernie Sanders
to become president because if Bernie
gets in there Bernie does let's say
Universal Health Care well that puts
Obamacare to shame because Obamacare is
this you know terrible half measure
which keeps the for-profit health
insurance companies in control and so
yeah I mean he he was screwed for the
audience said there's a no you real
quick but I mean obviously you you've
done very well you have a YouTube
channel that's done well I think you got
a billion views on YouTube you were with
Jank from 13 to 21 uh uh and then you
got your own thing that you're doing and
you've been around you know we just you
just tell us who you're engaged is it
public can we yeah yeah everybody knows
crystal ball Crystal Ball from the hill
she's a rock star uh you know her her
show everybody was following her in her
apartment soccer yeah they were doing a
great job but uh so you're that's that's
your background that's what you believe
in so if you were to kind of say well
these are the issues that I support this
is who I am what would those things be
yeah I mean it's very simple I would
just describe it as social democracy
okay so anybody can go to the Wikipedia
page for social social democracy and
read through it and that's basically
what my beliefs are so
um I believe in I believe in meritocracy
I might be surprised to hear that right
but I want the floor to be a reasonable
floor so I want people to have the
basics met and then from that yeah then
you achieve the most that you can so in
other words we're running 100 yard dash
yep I want everybody starting at the
zero yard line I don't want somebody at
the negative 40 yard line and then Mitt
Romney's son at the 85-yard line I want
to have a fair race I want a real
meritocracy so that means I want
everybody to have health care I want
everybody to have education I want
everybody to have the option potentially
of going to say trade school I want a
living wage for people so if they work a
full-time job they make enough money to
survive it's very basic stuff that I'm
talking about here I'm talking about
what I think the best countries in the
world at this point have already
achieved if you look at the Scandinavian
countries a lot of those countries uh
they they provide the basics for people
but then they also rank high and I think
you guys will appreciate this economic
freedom so a lot of these countries
score higher on like free market
principles than than our country does so
they cut all the red tape that you can
cut when it comes to business but they
also have the basics met for everybody
that's all I want I just want everybody
to you know get out what you put in
because certainly in the system we have
right now I think people feel like
they're getting a raw deal because they
are what do you think was common and
Adam I know you wanted to ask a question
so what do you think what commonalities
did you see between Trump and Bernie
like when you looked at the two what did
you say Okay obviously they don't agree
here they don't agree here they don't
but there is a lot of similarity here
what were some similarities yeah in the
two so that's a great question I would
say the similarities are an affectation
and posture so
um Trump came in in 2016 as an
anti-establishment Firebrand on the
right and I would say that a lot of his
rhetoric back then was very populist he
would he said in the 60 Minutes
interview yeah I'm gonna give everybody
health care and they're like who's gonna
pay for it he goes yeah the government's
gonna pay for it this is not something
you'd hear Mitt Romney or any other
Republican say
um he also said hey I'm uh I'm
self-financing my campaign now the
details of that are not exactly correct
but still the posture was there very
famously you know debate he's he pointed
at Jeb Bush and everybody else on stage
and said you hear those people clapping
the audience that's his donors I don't
have any donors in the audience and this
is stuff that people like it was the
same thing yeah it was sick when he
called out the Iraq War to Jeb Bush's
face in the middle of a republican
debate in a military State I think it
was North Carolina and the audience
clapped and it was at that moment I
think it was actually Ben Shapiro who
made this point it was 100 correct he
said on Twitter oh this thing's over and
this was early in the race if you can
get a military crowd in North Carolina
full of Republicans against the Iraq War
it's over and so I think that the
anti-establishment uh Firebrand is what
Trump brought to the table and Bernie
brought the same thing on the left so I
think the 2016 iteration of trump was
populist right and Bernie I think has
always been kind of populist left
um and they tapped into a real anger now
of course I think their Solutions are
very different and I don't agree with
Trump's solution I think he governed
more or less as kind of a standard
establishment Republican in many ways
but in terms of how he presented to the
country it was very clear that uh he was
taking this populist right
anti-establishment lane
this certain populace always kind of
bewilders me it's like populism so I
kind of want to break down what it
actually means to be popular you're
basically saying Trump was the populist
right in many fashions for sure Biden
populist left by definition what
populist just you're popular you're
saying things that the majority of
people want to hear but obviously Bernie
what he stands for is wildly different
than what Trump stands for so I guess my
question is how can they both be
populous what's the overlap right there
I'm sure a lot of people who supported
Trump would have actually voted for
Bernie because they kind of want to just
burn down the establishment break down
kind of what you think populism is today
well I would say it's just hatred of the
establishment and you saw that among
Trump voters you saw that among Bernie
voters the literal definition would be
something more along the lines of you
know doing the will of the people which
is true but I think that the connecting
tissue is that like anger at the system
whereas you look at somebody like
Hillary Clinton and it was like support
of the system prop up the system explain
why I think the system is good you look
at somebody like Joe Biden same thing
you look at somebody like Mitt Romney on
the writer you know the other Jeb Bush
these people are hey we got a good thing
going on here the institutions are kind
of working so let's not fiddle with it
too much right that's their argument
whereas the trumps and the Bernies are
like this [ __ ] thing is broken and
that's why you guys are angry and so I'm
gonna help you change that so with all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks right if you believe future
looks bright get your latest Future
looks bright hat of valuetainment it
says future looks right here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]